in 2009 we were presented with a  technical challenge to simulate  messy curly hair for the heroine merida  as well as support the various  hairstyles needed for the film brave  we began to explore the physics of curly  hair and to build the taz hair  simulation system  sadly soon after we finished the first  merida shots for the film's trailer we  lost andy witkin  one of the principal designers of taz  andy was our friend  our colleague and our mentor we couldn't  have achieved this without him  however thanks in large part to andy's  vision and the efforts of our team  we were able to achieve the previously  unachievable with cgi hair  it has been used on nearly every single  pixar film sense and has emboldened  artists both at pixar and throughout the  industry to push  the boundaries of character design we'd  like to thank the academy for this great  honor which we proudly dedicate to our  colleague andy  you